étage entouré de quelques amis il ya
beaucoup de photographes de caméraman de
journalistes mais aussi des curieux
comme si à 15 heures précises
il allait forcément se passer quelque
chose
je suis présent certaines personnes
c'est que je crois pas que l'ultimatum
va vraiment est apporté quelque chose à
trois heures c'est une nouvelle puce et
la famille de morphine la fellation et
le pape ce matin a fait une opération
aussi émettant va voir
et ça ça peut avoir des résultats vous
pensez que les brigades rouges peuvent
se laisser ses visées par ça et magique
à qunu en tout cas j'espère
il est 15 heures devant le siège de la
démocratie chrétienne place jésus les
dirigeants sont en réunion permanente à
l'intérieur au deuxième étage
là aussi on attend quelque chose comme
si les terroristes allaient se
manifester à 15 heures précises la
démocratie chrétienne a fait connaître
sa position
pas de négociation en vue de libérer des
terroristes mais appel humanitaire à
travers la société caritas international
vous êtes sympathisant de la démocratie
vous êtes venus pour prendre des
nouvelles de faire des nouvelles du
président de l'an on en a
face au toujours que il y a des cas qui
ont pas se passer comme ça enfin aller
s'enterrer ce problème comment le
résoudre
c'est un vol
libérez aldo moro est bien pour la
première fois le pape aussi s'est
adressé directement aux brigades rouges
humblement en implorant leur clémence
je vous en prie à genoux a dit paul 6
libéré moreau sans condition appel
pathétique qui a provoqué une grande
émotion à rome mais avec ces deux
interrogations
est-ce que d'une part paul 6 crois
vraiment que les terroristes vont
entendre son appel
est-ce que d'autre part paul 6 n'a pas
accordé une certaine légitimité aux
brigades rouges
n'y at-il pas le risque d'amplifier de
rendre considérable l'action des
terroristes
si ces pauses 600 personnes qui
s'adressaient à m vous l'avez compris
l'italie n'est pas encore l'heure d'été
lorsqu il est 15 heures à rome il est 16
heures à paris
si vous avez suivi avec nous ce midi
notre émission samedi et demi qui était
diffusé en direct de la capitale
italienne
vous avez certainement constaté que tous
les italiens condamne l'action
entreprise par les brigades rouges et
que ces mêmes italiens qu'ils soient
politiciens et journalistes et où homme
de la rue s'interrogent ils
s'interrogent sur le sort bien sûr
réservé à monsieur aldo moro
mais il s'interroge aussi sur les
raisons qui ont poussé certains des
italiens à se lancer dans l'action perd
patience et demande aussi vraiment à les
brigades rouges ont l'intérêt tuer ses
pommes on se demande vraiment s'il n'ya
pas encore des espaces des négociations
d'ailleurs nous ne pouvons pas imposer
aux institutions une position nous avons
dit clairement que les institutions ne
doit pas négocier nous avons dit
clairement que il ya un aspect humain de
cette situation et un aspect est publié
jeudi que nous avons apprécié la
teignouse du parti démocrate jan dorcel
circonstances difficiles et que les
parties de nos chrétiens en ce moment
toute notre solidarité nous pensons que
il ne faut pas négocier avec la brigade
revanche quoi qui ne sont pas contraires
ça peut donner des résultats lowe's
appel humanitaire mais il ne faut pas
négocier parce que c'est un danger
c'est cet oubli mais est-ce que vous
êtes un peu responsables comme le
laissait entendre que la gravité
allemand nous considérons que les
brigades rouges se passe à 200 méchant
garçon congo dit tous à peu près pas de
ce panel
il s'agit d'un groupe d'assassins qui
sont ennemis de la république tchèque
quoique on est un nouvel outil national
elle est entraînée c'est la
multinationale du crime n'est ce pas
alors qui peut nous dire que oui que non
qu'il n'y a pas de l'isu mois écoutez
moi je crois personnellement je crois
que oui c'est à dire que c'est un
phénomène un phénomène à l'échelle
européenne
donc rien d'exceptionnel qu'il y ait des
liaisons entre mouvements et l'autre au
en avoir la certitude
ben ça c'est beaucoup me demandez bien
sûr mais le je crois que si vous voulez
c'est international des enragés
je le dirai et je ne voudrais pas
l'international des contestataires qu'il
n'yad'autre qui contestent aussi et avec
a construit autant de vigueur qui nous
autres mais s'enfuit l'oublieront pas
contre l'extrême gauche et les
terroristes régaleront s'il est bien sûr
quelle est l'histoire personnelle
décision quels ont été leurs déceptions
qu'est ce qu'ils attendaient de la vie
et pourquoi ils ont été déçus à tel
point que mettra n'exite pas à tuer des
innocents
alors je crois que pour la venger
répondent jamais à votre question il
faut des d'avoir d'abord savoir
qu'est-ce qui est so est au juste
chacun premier et après seulement après
on pourra peut être dire voilà ce qu'ils
veulent
des questions que l'on se pose est
effectivement il ya quelques mois à
propos de la bande à baader et que l'on
est obligé de se poser aussi aujourd'hui
à propos des brigades rouges italiennes
en politique française un sondage il y
avait longtemps que nos confrères de la
presse écrite n'avait pas publié les
résultats d'une enquête d'opinion
aujourd'hui c'est le nouvel observateur
qui revient avec la sofres sur les
élections des 12 et 19 mars derniers et
la sofres
donne en chiffres les explications au
plus tôt une explication à la défaite de
la gauche selon cet institut de sondage
5% des électeurs ont modifié leurs
intentions de vote en 24 heures entre le
samedi 11 et le dimanche 12 mars et sur
ses 5 % qui ont changé d'avis 80 % sont
allés vers la majorité et 20% seulement
vers la gauche ce changement d'attitude
s'est fait dans 35% des cas nous dit la
sofres au dernier moment c'est-à-dire
dans l'isoloir et dans 15 autres pour
cent à l'issue de l'intervention le
samedi soir du président giscard
d'estaing dans le domaine politique week
end calme de réunion seulement le
conseil politique du cds se réunit
aujourd'hui et demain cette réunion
aboutir à semble-t-il un changement
assez léger monsieur jean lecanuet
resterait président du cds mais il n'en
serait plus le porte-parole officiers
autre réunion celle du carrefour social
démocrate un mouvement animé par
monsieur paul rue et le noir ainsi que
par madame christiane scrivener des
détails sur cette réunion qui se tient
encore actuellement lors de notre
dernière édition aux alentours de 23
heures alors que la situation militaire
paraît toujours très confuse au tchad
monsieur louis ii guy rannou
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères a reçu ce matin monsieur
critiques le ministre des affaires
étrangères de la libye
durant cette réunion on a surtout parlé
du tchad et les deux ministres ont
déploré la rupture du cessez-le-feu dans
ce pays paris et tripoli ont également
souligné la nécessité d'une solution
politique par la voie de la négociation
le parti communiste espagnol n'est plus
depuis hier soir un parti léniniste
désormais tu es c'est le premier
résultat du 9e congrès du pc le parti de
monsieur santiago carillo sera qualifié
de parti marxiste démocratique et
révolutionnaire
pariant les participants à ce congrès du
parti communiste se sont prononcés en
faveur de l'unité action immédiate avec
le parti socialiste ouvrier espagnol de
monsieur felipe gonzalez premières
réactions à l'étranger à ce changement
de trajectoire du parti communiste
espagnol
elle nous vient à d'albanie où monsieur
santiago carillo est accusé je cite
d'être devenu un laquais de la
bourgeoisie est un traître au marxisme
léninisme monsieur leonid brejnev a reçu
ce matin le secrétaire d'état américain
monsieur cyrus vans le numéro un de la
diplomatie américaine est à moscou
pour mener les négociations sur la
limitation des armements stratégiques la
conversation a duré deux bonnes heures
elle a été qualifiée d' utile par le
porte parole américain dutil
mais aussi de sans surprise du côté
soviétique cet entretien et ceux qui
m'ont précédé ans que monsieur cyrus
vans et gromyko ont été jugés structure
ce qui en langage diplomatique n'est pas
forcément significatif des français ont
manifesté cet après-midi à cologne ces
français ancien prisonnier de guerre ou
bien des portes et on entendait ainsi
protester contre l'éventuelle tenue à la
fin du mois d'une réunion d'anciens ss
de la brigade et de la division das
reich venus de 21 pays manifester contre
les mouvements néo-nazis quand la montée
commence à inquiéter les allemands eux
mêmes ils étaient vingt milles environ
dans les rues de cologne cet après midi
parmi eux deux mille français anciens
déportés et résistants motifs de cette
action
'l'annonce d'un rassemblement des
anciens ss de la division das reich
dimanche prochain à willems pen dimanche
qui sera justement en france la journée
nationale de la déportation insultes et
provocations 10 alors les survivants des
camps de la mort qui demandent la
dissolution des associations d'anciens
ss un avion peut-il faire une erreur de
5000 kilomètres dans sa destination si
quelqu'un trouve une réponse à cette
question la sphère du boeing 707 des
lignes aériennes coréenne a résonné
avant-hier soir par l'aviation chasse
soviétique sera probablement résolu ce
boeing phrases courtes et 97 passagers
et 13 membres d'équipage étaient
attendus à anchorage en alaska
il s'est posé et contraint et forcé sur
un lac soviétique à 900 km de moscou non
loin de mourmansk de passagers en tout
cas ont été tuées et 13 autres blessées
les six français qui étaient à bord de
l'appareil sont sains et saufs
voilà pour le dossier étrangers de sept
jours
trois ouvriers ont été tués ce matin à
la suite d'une explosion dans une usine
cela s'est passé à créer une loi de
paris les trois hommes travaillaient au
sommet d'un silo remplie de poussière de
zinc effectuer les soudures à peine
avait il commencé leur tâche que le silo
explose a lyon les habitants de la
capitale de la région rhône alpes ont
découvert aujourd'hui avec plaisir
semble-t-il les avantages de ce que l'on
appelle à paris le métropolite la
construction du métro de lyon est
terminée le réseau sera inaugurée la
semaine prochaine
par monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
grande première donc pour les lyonnais
conviés à découvrir leurs lignes de
métro ils ont vu un matériel roulant
dernier cri rapide très silencieux
confortable et peints de couleurs gaies
aujourd'hui ce n'était pour le public
qu'une prise de contact la mise en
service n'aura lieu qu'après
l'inauguration officielle fixée au 28
avril en présence du président de la
république
mais pour ce jour là les conducteurs ont
déjà déposé un préavis de grève au pire
donc les lyonnais attendront leur métro
quelques jours de plus après cinq années
de travaux le peintre jacques dupont est
mort hier soir à paris il avait 69 ans
jacques dupont était considéré comme
l'un des plus grands créateurs de décors
d'opéra et de théâtre à l'opéra il avait
réalisé notamment les coptes dont carlos
et de tirant d'eau à la comédie
française l'une de ses plus grandes
réussites avait été le prince travesti
de marivaux qui déclencha au lever du
rideau il ya quelques années de telle
rafale d'applaudissements que les
comédiens durent attendre plus de deux
minutes avant de lancer la première
réplique l'opéra l'orchestré symphonique
du de pékin sera en direct sur france
musique
c'est la grande première que nous
offrira demain matin france musique pour
la première fois un public occidental en
effet écoutée en direct par satellite
la retransmission d'un concert donné
dans la plus grande salle de concert de
la capitale chinoise quatre sont
inscrits au programme deux oeuvres
occidentale de berlioz et de best-of et
deux oeuvres chinoises encore jamais
entendu en occident
à un moment donné il faut que des pays
qui tendent aux mêmes objectifs
artistiques ce qui est maintenant le cas
avec la chine la france puisque la chine
est d'entrer dans le milieu culturel
occidental depuis que les orques et
chinois ont recommencé à jouer la
musique occidentale classique avec
l'absolu mans barré en tout la
révolution culturelle il nécessaire donc
qui est des échanges et une opération
originale comme celle là est venu à
l'esprit parce que ce que france musique
de faire c'est faire connaître à tous
les auditeurs ce qui se fait en fait de
musique dans le monde entier
il est à peu près sûr que jamais un
concert symphonique en stéréophonie n'a
été retransmis en direct sur une telle
distance
c'est une un pari c'est un challenge
comme les anglo saxons que les
ingénieurs de la radio et ceux des
télécommunications ont relevé avec un
enthousiasme et tout le monde est
mobilisé pour faire passer ce signal
stéréophonique de pékin à paris c'est
une des aventures à quelque sorte un
concert qui vous est donc faire de
m'appartient pas à ce qu'ils le
directeur de france musique et aussi par
philippe caloni début de la
retransmission demain à 10h30 sur france
musique le châtiment corporel et ils
barbares où l'on si je vous pose cette
question ce soir c'est khaled actuelle
ce grave problème se pose en effet en
grande bretagne dans l'île de même la
fessée vigoureusement asséné à coude du
made in de l'eau fait partie des
traditions
or la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme n'est pas d'accord avec cette
tradition millénaire devant ce docte
tribunal les raisons avancées par les
habitants de l'île domaine n'ont guère
d'écho alors claude gagnaire notre
envoyé spécialà grande bretagne a voulu
voir cela de plus près je me demande si
les raisons avancées dans cette fictive
qui dépend tout de même de la couronne
britannique ne vont pas trouver vous
avez constaté un écho favorable sur le
continent sinon du côté des juristes au
moins du côté des particules
c'est ainsi qu'est l'île de man on punit
ceux qui se sont rendus coupables de
coups et blessures
la trique et d'administrer aussitôt
après le jugement dans une salle de
police par un policier volontaires la
personne à punir est amené dans cette
pièce par cette porte
elle est conduite près de cette table on
lui ordonne de défaire son pantalon et
de laisser tomber à terre et de secours
vers au dessus de la table
vous êtes comme ça à peu près tout et
vous tapez dessus mais c'est là deux
policiers vous tiennent par les bras
pour que vous ne tombiez pas vous
comprenez et si vous résistez que vous
visitiez ou pas ils vous poète mais
comment fait-il comment frappe-t-il il
tient le fouet comme ça entre ses mains
les larmes son bras là vous voyez en
fait comme si je jouais au golf quoi et
comme une corvée vous reçu 6 ça fait mal
comment j'écris et je me merlet et la
punition fait mal nous l'avons demandé
mais c'est la loi d'une loi d'une
rigoureuse précision dont je vous
traduis quelques articles articles 15 si
une personne de sexe masculin qui a
atteint l'âge de 17 ans mais pas
dépasser 21 ans est condamné par la cour
pour un délit dans lequel il ya eu
agression ray coups et blessures
la cour peut ordonner en plus des autres
punitions que le condamné soit fouette
il y à un autre article pour les moins
de 17 ans
l'instrument utilisé dans le cas d'un
enfant est une ba dinh dans tous les
autres cas des verges de boulot la cour
précisera le nombre de coups infligés
pour un enfant pas plus de 6 à
l'adolescent à plus de 12
un adulte 20 au maximum jamais disent
des habitants de l'île de man
nous n'accepterons d'abroger une loi qui
est efficace et ils sont tous prêts à
créer un différend internationale alors
qui sont ces gens qui aiment ainsi le
père fouettard man est une petite île
entre l'angleterre et l'irlande tout
petit
soixante mille habitants et presque
indépendante
les manches les gens des îles sont des
sujets de sa majesté mais pas des sujets
britanniques
ils ont leurs institutions leurs
parlements leur passeport
on vit ici de la pêche de l'agriculture
de la petite industrie et des banques
les impôts sont nettement moins élevés
qu'en grande bretagne il y fait doux et
la paire n 126 policiers sur l'île et
qui n'ont rien à faire
c'est même surprenant le commissariat du
coin qui a des airs de cottage est fermé
à 5h une pancarte précise qu'en cas
d'urgence il ya un téléphone public à
150 l'heure
le dernier meurtre remonte à 1973 le
précédent croit ton à 1930 enfin le
troisième à 1914 avant on ne sait plus
il ya eu l'an dernier
trois vols pour les habitants de l'île
aucun doute
on doit cette paix à la peur du fouet
alors lorsqu'il ya trois ans la
commission européenne des droits de
l'homme jugé la punition dégradants et
demandé son abrogation sur l'île
c'était la révolution pas de fouet pas
de discipline scandé 4000 personnes
descendues dans la rue pour demander le
maintien de la loi mais à strasbourg au
nom de l'intérêt général ont décidé de
porter l affaire devant les instances
supérieures
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui doit rendre son verdict mardi
voilà alors pour calmer les motions des
juges européens depuis quelques temps on
ne fait plus baisser le pantalon des
condamnés et ça ne plaît pas aux
habitants par à madame irving par
exemple qui a recueilli 30 et une 1000
signatures sur 45 mille adultes que
compte l'île pour qu'on applique la loi
de partout elle reçoit du courrier de
grande-bretagne d'australie de nouvelle
zélande des gens qui disent bravo rester
ferme
le châtiment corporel a été aboli en
grande bretagne en 1948 et depuis les
crimes n'ont cessé d'augmenter les
vauriens les canailles se moque bien de
l'autorité maintenant qu'il n'ya rien
pour les dissuader les arrêter il y a
des gens qui sont profondément mauvais
ils sont le diable est le seul moyen de
les empêcher d'agresser les autres c'est
de menacer leur propre chair de leur
faire mal physiquement non le fouet
n'est pas inhumain bien sûr ça blesse la
dignité
personne n'aime qu'on lui demande de se
déculotter mais vous savez à propos que
la loi récemment changé sur l'île et
qu'on ne fait plus baisser le pantalon
et vous le regrettez nous le regrettons
beaucoup
le symbole de cette société permissive
qui bouleverse madame irving c'est ce
bateau le ferry boat qui fait la navette
entre lille et l'angleterre et amène les
vauriens de liverpool ou glasgow
c'est pour eux qu'on veut conserver la
loi le capitaine du ferry m'a raconté
qu'un jour ces agités avaient envahi son
bateau il avait donc pris son porte-voix
et averti les passagers qu aussitôt
quitté les eaux territoriales anglaise
chacun relever de la loi de lille
l'atmosphère avait jure at il
immédiatement change
on remercie même aujourd'hui la cour des
droits de l'homme d'avoir fait tant de
publicité à la loi du fouet depuis les
délits ont encore diminué sur l'île
on y voit la preuve de la force de
dissuasion des verges de boulot et cette
thèse a été développé pendant le procès
par l'envoyé du gouvernement de l'île de
man a strasbourg même ceux qui en ont
une expérience demeure fermement en
faveur de la tunisie
ça a été vraiment une leçon oui c'est
l'été et maintenant est-ce que vous
gardez votre sang le problème est qu
l'île de man n'est pas tout à fait
indépendant et en particulier pour les
affaires de politique étrangère elle est
représentée par les britanniques est
donc la grande bretagne puissance
tutélaire avait envoyé son représentant
à strasbourg
monsieur blom cooper chargé par l'ondh
de dire que la grande bretagne avait
aboli les châtiments corporels que ces
châtiments aller contre les règles de la
société des droits de l'homme que le
fouet de son opinion n'avait aucun effet
dissuasif mais que les gens de l'île de
man semblait penser différemment et en
effet le représentant de man que voici
se battait lui pour convaincre les juges
que la punition était efficace et
dissuasive et accepté par tout le monde
il invité les juges à venir se rendre
compte que même sur place de l'état
d'esprit de la population
les juges refusé et pourtant c'est vrai
la population est unanime
ce barbu sympathique qui n'a pas l'air
d'un bourreau directeur d'école répond
que lui et son épouse avec et 31 mille
autres habitants ont signé la pétition
est ce que les juges européens ne
verront pas et c'est dommage c'est
l'évidence de la conscience de la
population qui a poussé le débat
jusqu'en des lieux inattendus
regardez ya tout juste cinq branches est
si légère retourne toi rita je te fais
mal
bien sûr que non d'ailleurs je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on fait tant de
bruit autour de ça en fait le vrai
problème pour les habitants de man n'est
pas le fouet mais bien le droit de
décider eux mêmes de ce qui est bon ou
pas pour leur petite communauté
portuaire je vois mal dit le
représentant du gouvernement il de man
les anglais nous envoyer des soldats
pour nous contraindre à abandonner une
punition à sous